Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In late April 1972, a serious matter was unravelling at the West Friedhoff mortuary in Nuremberg, Germany. Several relatives of the recently deceased had noticed a jewellery missing from their loved one's bodies.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1972年4月下旬，德国纽伦堡的西弗里德霍夫（West Friedhoff）停尸房发生了一起严重的案件。几位近期逝者的亲属发现，死者遗体上的珠宝不翼而飞。
The cadavers had been stored in the facility's crematorium prior to burial, where at some point the jewellery would vanish. The bereaved expressed their concerns to the mortuary's night watchman, 47-year-old Georg Varmut. Complaints like these weren't unusual. The missing items would usually be found at the home of the deceased, having never been on their body in the first place. Other times, mortuary staff would remove the high-value items and store them in a small
这些尸体在下葬前被存放在该设施的火化间里，珠宝正是在某个时候消失的。痛失亲人的家属向停尸房的夜间看守人——47岁的格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特（Georg Varmut）表达了他们的担忧。像这样的投诉并不罕见。失踪的物品通常会在死者家中找到，因为它们一开始就根本没戴在遗体上。有时，停尸房的工作人员会取下高价值的物品，并将它们存放在一个小
chest for safe keeping. It was only a matter of time before they reappeared. This time, however, Georg was beginning to suspect something was amiss. Upon entering the mortuary's waiting room one day, Georg found a money box displaced on a table. It had been forced open and emptied. During no evidence of a break-in, Georg believed that the culprit was likely someone who worked at the mortuary or the adjoining Nuremberg West Cemetery.
箱子里妥善保管。这些东西重新出现只是时间问题。然而这一次，格奥尔格开始怀疑有些不对劲。一天，当格奥尔格走进停尸房的休息室时，发现桌上的一个钱箱被移位了。它被强行撬开并洗劫一空。由于没有入室盗窃的迹象，格奥尔格认为罪魁祸首很可能是停尸房或毗邻的纽伦堡西公墓的工作人员。
To avoid causing tension amongst his colleagues or tarnishing the reputation of his workplace, Georg kept his suspicions to himself. He began investigating the matter discreetly, with the intention to confront the perpetrator once he had identified them. A six-foot-tall, burly war veteran, Georg felt more than capable of handling any ensuing conflict. The following days were uneventful. Then a storm rolled in on the night of May 5.
为了避免在同事中引起紧张气氛或玷污工作场所的名誉，格奥尔格将自己的怀疑藏在心里。他开始暗中调查此事，打算一旦查出凶手就与其实质对质。格奥尔格身高六英尺，是一名身材魁梧的退伍军人，他觉得自己完全有能力处理任何随之而来的冲突。接下来的几天风平浪静。直到5月5日夜里，一场风暴袭来。
Georg Varmut took shelter at his home next to the mortuary. He was watching television and thinking over the recent spate of thefts when the phone rang. On the other line was one of his neighbours, a woman who lived opposite the cemetery. She reported seeing a dark figure moving quickly between the graves. Suspecting it was the thief, Georg rushed to the mortuary. He hid patiently in the darkness on the mezzanine floor, waiting for the thief to appear. When they failed to do so, Georg sought them out.
格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特在停尸房旁边的家中避难。他正在看电视，脑子里盘算着最近发生的一系列盗窃案，这时电话铃响了。电话那头是他的一个邻居，一个住在公墓对面的女人。她报告说看到一个黑影在墓碑之间快速移动。格奥尔格怀疑是小偷，便冲向停尸房。他耐心地藏在夹层的黑暗中，等待小偷出现。当小偷没有出现时，格奥尔格便主动去找他。
His search led him to the crematorium. Georg turned out the lights and waited in the shadows. He heard the door creak open. A slim, short-statured man with the jet-black hair entered the secure area and slowly made his way to a nearby coffin. It contained the body of a 15-year-old girl who had arrived the previous day. Georg watched as the intruder leant into the coffin and kissed the corpse on the lips. This was one of many disturbing incidents that had occurred at a German mortuary or
他的搜寻将他带到了火化间。格奥尔格关掉灯，在阴影中等待。他听到门发出吱呀的开门声。一个身材苗条、个子不高、留着漆黑头发的男子进入了安保区，慢慢走向附近的一口棺材。里面装着一具15岁女孩的遗体，她是前一天被送到这里的。格奥尔格看着闯入者探身进棺材，吻了吻尸体的嘴唇。这是最近一段时间内在德国停尸房或
cemetery in recent times. A year earlier, on April 14, 1971, a staff member at the Ulstorff Cemetery in Hamburg entered the mortuary and stumbled across a horrific scene. The body of a girl had been removed from her coffin and posed so that she was leaning against it. She was naked and her lips and neck were bruised with visible bite marks. Placed beside her were two burnt-out candles. She was surrounded by the bodies of other corpses that had also been removed from their
公墓发生的一系列令人不安的事件之一。一年前，即1971年4月14日，汉堡乌尔斯多夫（Ulstorff）公墓的一名工作人员走进停尸房，无意中撞见了一个可怕的场景。一个女孩的尸体从棺材里被取了出来，并被摆成靠着棺材的姿势。她是赤裸的，她的嘴唇和脖子上有明显的咬痕淤青。在她身旁放着两根烧尽的蜡烛。她被其他同样从
coffins. They were sitting up, facing the girl. Three days later, 64 kilometers east of Hamburg, an undertaker was met by a similar scene when he walked into his parlour. The body of a recently deceased 40-year-old woman was sitting up outside of her coffin, surrounded by burnt-out candles. Then, on the island of Silt in the North Sea, a pastor headed over to his church. The body of a 52-year-old man was lying in a coffin inside, ready to be laid to rest.
棺材中被移出的尸体包围着。他们坐着，面向女孩。三天后，在汉堡以东64公里处，一名殡葬师走进他的会客室时，也遇到了类似的场景。一具刚去世不久的40岁女尸坐在棺材外面，周围环绕着烧尽的蜡烛。接着，在北海的叙尔特（Silt）岛上，一名牧师前往他的教堂。里面一口棺材里躺着一具52岁男子的尸体，准备入土为安。
The pastor had made sure the coffin was closed when he left the previous evening. But, as he entered the church that day, the lid was open. Worse still, protruding from the man's chest was a hunting knife. In May, a woman named Marion was walking through the Moulin Cemetery in the town of Flensborg. As she drew closer to her mother's burial plot, she noticed someone sitting on the adjoining gravesite. Marion was shocked to realize that the grave had been dug up.
牧师前一天晚上离开时确保棺材是关好的。但是，当他那天走进教堂时，盖子是开着的。更糟糕的是，从这名男子的胸口突出一把猎刀。五月份，一个名叫玛丽安（Marion）的女人正穿过弗伦斯堡（Flensborg）镇的莫兰（Moulin）公墓。当她走近母亲的墓地时，她注意到有人坐在相邻的墓地上。玛丽安震惊地发现那个坟墓被挖开了。
The person sitting was the body of the man who'd been buried there. He had been decapitated, and his head was missing. Months later, on November 6th, a man was visiting a cemetery in Foyt to pay his respects to a deceased relative. While walking through the grounds, he spotted a grave that had been dug up. The coffin within had been prized open, and the naked body of a young girl was sitting upright on the mound of dirt. When Vestfriedorf mortuary night watchman Georg Varmut came across the intruder kissing
坐在那里的是埋葬在那里的男人的尸体。他被斩首了，头部不见了。几个月后的11月6日，一名男子正在参观福伊特（Foyt）的一处公墓，以悼念一位已故的亲属。在墓地里漫步时，他发现了一个被盗掘的坟墓。里面的棺材被撬开，一个年轻女孩赤裸的尸体正端坐在土堆上。当韦斯特弗里德霍夫（Vestfriedorf）停尸房夜间看守格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特撞见闯入者亲吻
the corpse, he immediately leapt into action. The perpetrator, realizing he'd been caught in the act, made a break for the exit. Georg chased after him, grabbing him by the collar as he reached the door. He pulled the man into a nearby elevator where the diffused light illuminated the man's face. He was a strange-looking individual aged in his 30s with spectacles and a bulbous nose. He didn't utter a word. A loud bang interrupted the pair's altercation as Georg was hit by a painful blow.
尸体时，他立即采取了行动。肇事者意识到自己被当场抓获，便夺路而逃。格奥尔格紧追不舍，在嫌疑人到达门口时抓住了他的领子。他把这名男子拉进附近的一部电梯里，柔和的光线照亮了这名男子的脸。这是一个长相怪异的30多岁男子，戴着眼镜，有着一个硕大的鼻子。他一言不发。一声巨响打断了两人的争吵，格奥尔格受到沉重的一击。
Blood seeped from his upper abdomen into his shirt. He let go of the intruder, who was holding a smoking 7.65mm pistol, and fell to the ground. The gunman grinned at the wounded Georg before taking off. Georg crawled on all fours to the telephone in his office. He called emergency services, then dragged himself to the bathroom to tend to his injury. The bullet had damaged his small and large intestines as well as his bladder. But Georg survived. Police arrived and sealed off the mortuary, but the gunman was long gone.
鲜血从他的上腹部渗入衬衫。他松开了拿着一支冒烟的7.65毫米手枪的闯入者，倒在地上。持枪者对受伤的格奥尔格咧嘴一笑，然后逃跑了。格奥尔格手脚并用地爬到办公室的电话机旁。他拨打了急救电话，然后把自己拖到浴室去处理伤口。子弹损伤了他的小肠、大肠以及膀胱。但格奥尔格活了下来。警察赶到并封锁了停尸房，但枪手早已逃之夭夭。
Georg was able to provide a detailed description of his assailant. By the following day, 50 detectives were chasing up the alibis of known gravediggers, robbers, thieves and other criminals in the area. All of them were accounted for. When 24-year-old Marcus Adler met 19-year-old Ruth Lissy, it was love at first sight. The pair met three years earlier in Yugoslavia and had been inseparable since. Marcus and his mother ran a freight business in Ulberhausen, while Ruth was employed as a salesperson more than 470km away in Nuremberg.
格奥尔格能够提供袭击者的详细体貌特征。到第二天，50名侦探正在追查当地已知的掘墓人、强盗、小偷和其他罪犯的不在场证明。所有这些人都排除了嫌疑。当24岁的马库斯·阿德勒（Marcus Adler）遇到19岁的露丝·利西（Ruth Lissy）时，那是真正的日久生情。两人三年前在南斯拉夫相遇，此后形影不离。马库斯和他的母亲在乌尔伯豪森（Ulberhausen）经营一家货运公司，而露丝则在470多公里外的纽伦堡担任销售员。
Every chance that he got, Marcus drove the long journey in his light grey Mercedes to visit Ruth. On May 6, Marcus set out for the home where Ruth lived with her parents. After he arrived, the two decided to go for a drive together. They farewelled Ruth's mother at 6pm and left in Marcus's car. The young couple headed to a forest east of Nuremberg, a short drive from Ruth's home. After finding a scenic spot to park, the two dozed off, with Marcus in the front seat and Ruth lying in the back.
马库斯抓住每一个机会，开着他的浅灰色梅赛德斯汽车进行长途旅行去探望露丝。5月6日，马库斯动身前往露丝与父母同住的家。他到达后，两人决定一起开车兜风。他们在下午6点向露丝的母亲告别，坐着马库斯的车离开。这对年轻情侣前往纽伦堡以东的一片森林，距离露丝的家只有短途车程。找到一个风景优美的停车地点后，两人打起盹来，马库斯在前排座位上，露丝躺在后座。
Nearby, a short, bespectacled man drove through the forest on his red moped. It was the perfect place for him to lay low until the heat of the vest-free-dough mortuary shooting dissipated. He had spent the day exploring the wilderness where he carried out target practice. This particular forest was popular with hunters, so the sound of his shooting at traffic signs, trees and the occasional deer didn't attract any unwanted attention. The man was still there at dusk, riding around aimlessly when he spotted the light grey Mercedes with the sleeping couple inside.
附近，一个身材矮小、戴着眼镜的男子骑着他的红色轻便摩托车穿过森林。对他来说，这是潜伏起来直到西弗里德霍夫停尸房枪击案的风头过去的最完美地方。他花了一天时间探索荒野，并在那里进行打靶练习。这片特殊的森林深受猎人喜爱，因此他向路标、树木和偶尔出现的鹿开枪的声音并没有引起任何不必要的注意。黄昏时分，这名男子仍然在那里漫无目的地骑着车，这时他发现了停着那辆载着睡觉情侣的浅灰色梅赛德斯。
He pulled over and cautiously approached the car. He reached over and opened the driver's side door. The noise woke Marcus, prompting the man to pull out his 7.65mm pistol. He shot Marcus in the head, causing Ruth to sit up abruptly. The man shifted his attention to her, shooting her in the left side of her chest. He then leaned into the car and shot both of them execution-style, to make certain they were dead. Overwhelmed with impulse, the man climbed into the car and pressed his lips to Marcus' wounds,
他把车停下，小心翼翼地走近这辆车。他伸手打开了驾驶员侧的车门。声音吵醒了马库斯，促使这名男子拔出他的7.65毫米手枪。他朝马库斯的头部开枪，导致露丝猛地坐了起来。这名男子将注意力转移到她身上，击中了她的左胸。然后他探身进车里，以行刑式的手法朝两人开枪，以确保他们已经死亡。一股冲动涌上心头，这名男子钻进车里，将嘴唇贴在马库斯的伤口上，
sucking the blood from them. Once he'd had enough, he clambered into the backseat. He tore Ruth's sweater off, pushed up her bra, then licked the blood from her chest wound. After 10 minutes, he was overcome with a calming sense of satisfaction. He felt stronger than before. The man pulled off Ruth's engagement ring and rummaged through her purse. He found Marcus' wallet in the glove compartment. As he examined its contents, he noticed someone approaching the car.
吮吸着他们的血。吸够之后，他爬进了后座。他扯下露丝的毛衣，推起她的胸罩，然后舔舐她胸口伤口上的血。10分钟后，他被一种平静的满足感所淹没。他觉得自己比以前更强壮了。这名男子扯下露丝的订婚戒指，并在她的钱包里翻找起来。他在手套箱里找到了马库斯的钱包。当他检查里面的东西时，他注意到有人正朝车子走来。
A hunter was combing the edge of the forest when he spotted the light grey Mercedes parked up ahead. The hunter was standing nearby, acting nervously. It was a small man wearing a leather hat and sunglasses. He then rushed to a red moped parked five metres away and sped off. The hunter reached the Mercedes and peered through its windows, finding the bodies of Marcus Adler and Ruth Lissie inside. Shocked by the grisly discovery, the hunter fired his shotgun into the air to alert nearby
一名猎人正在梳理森林边缘，这时他发现了前方停着的浅灰色梅赛德斯。猎人站在附近，表现得很紧张。那是一个戴着皮帽和太阳镜的小个子男人。然后他冲向停在五米外的一辆红色轻便摩托车，加速逃走了。猎人走到梅赛德斯车前，透过车窗向内张望，发现里面躺着马库斯·阿德勒和露丝·利西的尸体。对这起可怕的发现感到震惊的猎人向空中开了一枪，以警告附近的
hikers and farmers that help was needed. There was no response. Left with no other option, he was forced to trek one and a half kilometres to the nearest foam booth, where he contacted police. Post mortems revealed that Marcus and Ruth's wounds had been sucked clean of blood. The double homicide occurred less than 24 hours after the shooting of Georg Varmut and in the same city. Investigators wondered if the two incidents were related.
徒步旅行者和农民需要救援。没有任何回应。别无选择，他被迫长途跋涉一公里半到达最近的泡沫亭，在那里他联系了警察。尸检显示，马库斯和露丝伤口上的血被吮吸得干干净净。这起双重谋杀案发生在枪击格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特后不到24小时，并且在同一个城市。调查人员想知道这两起事件是否有关联。
They compared the bullets retrieved from both crime scenes. They were a perfect match. The head of Nuremberg's homicide squad called the disturbed perpetrator a madman. We have to act fast, he asserted, otherwise there will be more deaths. A task force was swiftly formed to hunt down the killer, while a 6,000 Deutsche Mark reward was offered for his capture. His physical description was published in newspapers, along with an alert for the public to be on the lookout for his distinctive red moped.
他们对比了从两个犯罪现场找回的子弹。它们完全吻合。纽伦堡凶杀案调查组的负责人称这个精神错乱的肇事者是个疯子。我们必须采取行动，他断言，否则会有更多人丧生。当局迅速成立了一个特别工作组来追捕凶手，同时悬赏6000德国马克缉拿归案。他的体貌特征被刊登在报纸上，同时向公众发出警报，注意他那辆标志性的红色轻便摩托车。
Helmut Kostan was employed with a transit company based in Nuremberg. Four days after the Adler and Lissy slayings, Helmut picked up a copy of a local paper. The blood-sucking, gun-wielding madman terrorizing the city was still making headlines. Helmut was struck by the suspect's description. It reminded him of his colleague, 41-year-old Kuno Hoffman. Hoffman was a short-statured, black-haired man who wore spectacles and drove a red moped. Just a minute earlier, Hoffman had entered the manager's office and abruptly resigned from his job.
赫尔穆特·科斯坦（Helmut Kostan）受雇于纽伦堡的一家运输公司。在阿德勒和利西被害四天后，赫尔穆特拿起了一份当地报纸。这个在城市里恐怖施虐的吸血持枪疯子仍然占据着各大头条。赫尔穆特的注意力被嫌疑人的描述吸引住了。这让他想起了他的同事、41岁的库诺·霍夫曼（Kuno Hoffman）。霍夫曼是一个身材矮小、留着黑发、戴着眼镜并骑着红色轻便摩托车的男人。就在一分钟前，霍夫曼刚走进经理办公室，并突然辞去了工作。
He no longer wanted to work the docks loading boxes into trucks, instead expressing a desire to go to Hamburg. Hoffman had just left when Helmut Kostan came across his description in the local paper in relation to the recent killings. Helmut rushed to a phone and called the police. Kuno Hoffman was a troubled individual. Following his birth in 1931, he was violently beaten by his alcoholic father. At age one, Kuno's father shoved him into a sack and threw him away.
他再也不想在码头上干将箱子装上卡车的活了，而是表达了去汉堡的愿望。霍夫曼刚离开，赫尔穆特·科斯坦就在当地报纸上看到了与近期谋杀案有关的他的体貌描述。赫尔穆特冲到电话旁报了警。库诺·霍夫曼是一个饱受心理折磨的人。1931年出生后，他遭到酗酒父亲的暴力殴打。一岁时，库诺的父亲把他塞进麻袋里扔掉了。
On another occasion, young Kuno was hung from a wooden window frame and beaten. Kuno's mother claimed the brutal physical abuse had caused Kuno to become deaf and non-verbal. However, a doctor maintained that his permanent disabilities were the result of a middle-ear infection. Kuno's father remained an inconsistent presence throughout his childhood, often spending long stints in prison. He served time for burglary, child abuse, and the attempted murder of a woman he had raped.
还有一次，年幼的库诺被挂在木制窗框上殴打。库诺的母亲称，这种残酷的身体虐待导致库诺变成聋哑人。然而，一名医生坚称，他的永久残疾是中耳炎的结果。在库诺的童年时期，父亲一直是一个不稳定的存在，经常在监狱里度过漫长的时光。他曾因入室盗窃、虐待儿童以及企图谋杀一名被他强奸的妇女而服刑。
When his father was home, Kuno isolated himself to avoid his wrath. His parents eventually divorced in 1940. Kuno moved to between eight different schools for deaf children before taking on a shoemaker's apprenticeship. He gave up on that in a fit of rage, then took up work on an agricultural estate in Nuremberg. Although considered a diligent worker, Kuno lost his job when he demanded a higher wage. With an IQ of 70 and the inability to communicate, options were limited for Kuno.
当父亲在家时，库诺便孤立自己以避开他的怒火。他的父母最终于1940年离婚。库诺在八所不同的聋哑儿童学校之间辗转，之后当了一名鞋匠学徒。他在一阵愤怒中放弃了这份工作，随后在纽伦堡的一处农业庄园找到了一份工作。尽管被认为是一个勤奋的工人，但当库诺要求更高的工资时，他还是失去了工作。智商为70且无法与人沟通，库诺的选择非常有限。
His life from there on out was interspersed with odd jobs and crime. His first charge came in 1949 following the theft of a bicycle. By the 1950s, he was committing burglaries and arson. The courts tried to help Hoffman. He was placed into various medical and nursing homes, but the silent man remained an enigma to physicians. In total, he spent nine years in nursing homes and another nine in prison. Sometimes he accepted treatment willingly, other times, not so much.
从那以后，他的人生里穿插着零工和犯罪。他的第一次指控发生在1949年，起因是偷了一辆自行车。到了20世纪50年代，他一直在进行入室盗窃和纵火。法庭试图帮助霍夫曼。他被送进各种医疗和疗养院，但这个沉默寡言的男人对医生来说仍然是个谜。总共他在疗养院度过了九年，在监狱里度过了另外九年。有时他自愿接受治疗，有时则不然。
He exploited a lack of security measures in the homes where he was kept to escape on twelve occasions. By 1971, he had only spent five years of his adult life free of any type of incarceration. Hoffman went to live with his sister and brother in Nuremberg, where he picked up work. For the first time in a long time, Kuno Hoffman's life seemed to be on track. However, Hoffman was an unappealing man who was unable to form romantic relationships. He developed an addiction to pornography and took to visiting brothels in search of companionship. Yet, he felt the sex workers only aimed to get the job done and was left bitter by their
他利用所居住的疗养院缺乏安保措施的漏洞，先后十二次越狱。到1971年，他的成年生活中只有五年时间是没有遭受任何形式监禁的。霍夫曼去和他在纽伦堡的姐姐和兄弟同住，并在那里找了份工作。长期以来，库诺·霍夫曼的生活似乎第一次步入了正轨。然而，霍夫曼是一个没有吸引力的男人，无法建立恋爱关系。他患上了色情成瘾症，开始造访妓院以寻求陪伴。然而，他觉得性工作者只是为了完成任务，每当他们亲密接触时，她们流露出厌恶的表情，这让他感到痛苦。他渴望得到温柔而持久的爱。随着时间的推移，孤独吞噬了他。一度，他的姐姐让他买一个充气娃娃，但霍夫曼决心找到另一种改善自己处境的方法。
expressions of disgust whenever they were intimate with him. He desired to be loved tenderly and permanently. Over time, loneliness consumed him. At one stage, his sister told him to buy a rubber doll, but Hoffman was determined to find another way to improve his situation. Following the tip-off to police, six officers in four patrol cars quickly descended on Kuno Hoffman's workplace. Although he matched the description of the shooter wanted in relation to the Adler-Lissie
在向警方提供线索后，四辆巡逻车里的六名警官迅速包围了库诺·霍夫曼的工作场所。尽管他符合阿德勒-利西谋杀案中通缉的枪手的特征，但他的同事们实际上并不相信霍夫曼是凶手。在他们看来，他是一个无害的家伙。当警察来找他时，他们发现霍夫曼已经离开了现场。搜捕工作随即展开，机缘巧合下，他被发现藏在一辆卡车后面。他逃跑了，但很快被捕。
murders, his colleagues didn't actually believe Hoffman was responsible. He was, by their accounts, a harmless guy. When police came looking for him, they discovered Hoffman had since left the premises. A search commenced and, by chance, he was spotted hiding behind a truck. He took off, but was quickly apprehended. Police would come to discover that Kuno Hoffman was deaf and non-verbal and communicated using noiseless facial expressions and hand gestures. As such, an interpreter was summoned to facilitate communications between him and homicide detectives.
警方后来发现，库诺·霍夫曼是聋哑人，靠无声的面部表情和手势进行交流。因此，当局召集了一名口译员来协助他与凶杀案侦探之间的沟通。
The interview began at 6pm to enable more time for evidence gathering. The interpreter spoke on Hoffman's behalf and his answers were recorded. Throughout the 50-minute interrogation, Hoffman was caught lying and his version of events were contradictory. At one stage, police threatened Hoffman with a crowbar to get him to confess to the murders, yet he only admitted to things he wanted to. Meanwhile, Hoffman's room at the home he shared with his sister and brother was being searched.
审讯于下午6点开始，以便有更多时间收集证据。口译员代表霍夫曼发言，他的回答被记录下来。在长达50分钟的审讯中，霍夫曼被发现撒谎，他的事件版本前后矛盾。有一阶段，警察用撬棍威胁霍夫曼以让他承认谋杀，但他只承认了他自己想承认的事情。与此同时，霍夫曼与姐姐和兄弟同住的房间正在被搜查。
His red moped was found at the address, along with Ruth Lissie's engagement ring. The human skull that had been cut from a corpse in Moulin Cemetery was also amongst Hoffman's possessions. Others were a set of duplicate keys to the vest-free-dove mortuary and other items stolen from the crematorium. However, the murder weapon was still missing. Shortly before 9pm, an officer examining Hoffman's washing machine began unscrewing the appliance piece by piece.
他的红色轻便摩托车在该地址被找到，露丝·利西的订婚戒指也在那里。从莫兰公墓一具尸体上割下的人类头骨也在霍夫曼的财物中。其他的还有一套韦斯特弗里德霍夫（Vest-free-dove）停尸房的备用钥匙以及从火化间偷来的其他物品。然而，凶器仍然下落不明。晚上9点前不久，一名检查霍夫曼洗衣机的警官开始把这个家电一件一件地拆开。
Hidden within, he discovered a 7.65mm pistol. He contacted the detectives interviewing Hoffman to inform them of the discovery. When Hoffman was told of the find, his face twitched and lips trembled. He then began to motion with his hands. Over the next 20 minutes, he provided investigators with a confession. Hoffman read extensively and in 1966 purchased a book titled The Black Magic by an occultist group in Hamburg. The text fostered what would become a lifelong fascination of the dark arts.
藏在里面的是一把7.65毫米手枪。他联系了正在审讯霍夫曼的侦探，将这一发现告知他们。当霍夫曼被告知这一发现时，他的脸抽搐着，嘴唇颤抖着。接着他开始用双手比划。在接下来的20分钟里，他向调查人员供认了罪行。霍夫曼博览群书，并在1966年购买了一本由汉堡的一个神秘学团体撰写的名为《黑魔法》的书。这本书培养了他对黑魔法终生的迷恋。
Hoffman read up on various occult subjects like Satanism and soon harboured an obsession to self-improve using their teachings. He became infatuated by two particularly taboo subgroups, vampirism and necrophilia, the sexual attraction to or sexual acts involving corpses. Between 1971 and 72, Hoffman forced entry into cemeteries and mortuaries throughout Germany. He stole and duplicated building keys so he could move in and out with ease. Under the cover of darkness, he dug up fresh graves or entered crematoriums and began violating the deceased.
霍夫曼阅读了各种神秘学主题，如撒旦崇拜，并很快怀有一种利用其教义进行自我提升的痴迷。他迷上了两个特别禁忌的亚群：吸血鬼主义和恋尸癖，即对尸体的性吸引力或涉及尸体的性行为。在1971年至1972年间，霍夫曼强行闯入了德国各地的公墓和停尸房。他偷取并复制了建筑钥匙，以便自己能够轻松进出。在夜色的掩护下，他掘开新坟或进入火化间，开始亵渎逝者。
He stabbed them with knives and razors and drank their blood. Occasionally, he chewed their flesh, cut off their heads, removed their hearts or examined their internal organs. Sometimes, he'd manipulate several bodies at a single scene, posing them around each other. He'd also sexually interfere with the bodies of women he found attractive. He travelled to each location on his red moped. By May 1972, Hoffman had desecrated the remains of 35 individuals.
他用刀子和剃须刀刺他们并饮用他们的血。有时，他咀嚼他们的肉，砍下他们的头，取出他们的心脏或检查他们的内脏。有时，他在一个现场摆弄多具尸体，将他们相互摆出各种姿势。他还会对那些他觉得有吸引力的女性尸体进行性干扰。他骑着他的红色轻便摩托车前往每一个地点。到1972年5月，霍夫曼已经亵渎了35名死者的遗体。
Obituary notices published in newspapers helped him choose his victims. At one stage, his brother suspected he was up to something. He articulated to Hoffman, Say, are you crazy, Kuro? Why are you studying the obituaries in the papers? Why are you visiting the morgue for no reason? Do you want to enjoy the dead women? Hoffman did not respond, but the accusation made him increasingly cautious.
报纸上刊登的讣告帮助他选择了受害人。有一次，他的兄弟怀疑他在搞鬼。他对霍夫曼说：“库罗，你说你是不是疯了？你为什么要在报纸上研究讣告？你为什么无缘无故地去停尸房？难道你想享用死去的女人吗？”霍夫曼没有回应，但这种指责让他变得越来越谨慎。
Hoffman believed that by carrying out his black magic rituals and consuming the blood of his victims, he would become handsome and strong. He also thought it would give him back his hearing and voice. Only then would he have power over women. In the meantime, he had to impose his will on others through other means. He developed a fascination with pistols and rifles, which led to the purchase of a 7.4 0.65mm pistol for 500 Deutsche Marks. Hoffman had made duplicate keys to the vest Friedhof mortuary and entered the premises
霍夫曼相信，通过执行他的黑魔法仪式并饮用受害者的血，他会变得英俊而强壮。他还认为这会让他恢复听力和声音。只有那样，他才能对女性拥有权力。与此同时，他不得不通过其他方式将自己的意志强加于人。他对手枪和步枪产生了迷恋，这导致他花了500德国马克购买了一支7.4 0.65毫米手枪。霍夫曼配制了西弗里德霍夫停尸房的备用钥匙，并进入了该场所
on four occasions to steal valuables from the bodies stored there. He intended to do so again on the night of May 5, 1972. However, once inside, his plans changed. He wanted a pretty girl whose blood he could drink. Hoffman was already in the morgue when Georg Varmut entered, but because he was deaf, Hoffman did not hear the night watchman approach. Startled, he rushed to the exit. Hoffman pulled out his pistol on the way and shot Georg to facilitate his escape.
四次，从存放在那里的尸体上偷取贵重物品。1972年5月5日夜里，他打算故地重演。然而，一旦进入里面，他的计划改变了。他想要一个漂亮的女孩，好饮用她的血。当格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特进入时，霍夫曼已经在停尸房里了，但由于他是聋哑人，霍夫曼没有听到夜间看守的接近。大吃一惊的他冲向出口。霍夫曼在途中拔出手枪，开枪击中格奥尔格以便逃跑。
Once outside, he scrambled over the wooden fence surrounding the cemetery and climbed onto his red moped that he had hidden in nearby shrubbery. He then took off home. At 9 the following morning, Hoffman rode his moped to the forest east of Nuremberg, where he hid for the duration of the day. That evening, he came across Markus Adler and Ruth Lissie. He killed the couple and consumed their blood, telling detectives that the pretty young girl had been much better than the women in the graveyards.
一旦到了外面，他艰难地翻过环绕公墓的木栅栏，爬上了他藏在附近灌木丛中的红色轻便摩托车。然后他骑车回家。第二天早上9点，霍夫曼骑着他的摩托车来到纽伦堡以东的森林，在那里躲藏了一整天。那天晚上，他遇到了马库斯·阿德勒和露丝·利西。他杀死了这对情侣并饮用了他们的血，他告诉侦探，这个漂亮的年轻女孩比墓地里的那些女人好得多。
As the passerby had seen him and his distinct vehicle, Hoffman believed the police would track him down easily. He hid his pistol in his washing machine and promptly quit his job, hoping to flee the city before authorities caught up with him. Hoffman's former employers were shocked by his actions. They issued a statement that described Hoffman as a nice person and questioned how the unassuming man could be capable of carrying out such horrendous acts. Their character references were overwhelmingly positive, Hoffman hid his true nature well.
由于路人见过他和他的标志性车辆，霍夫曼相信警方很容易就能追踪到他。他把手枪藏在洗衣机里，并立即辞去了工作，希望能赶在当局追上他之前逃离这座城市。霍夫曼以前的雇主对他的行为感到震惊。他们发表了一份声明，将霍夫曼描述为一个好人，并质疑这个谦逊的人怎么能做出如此骇人听闻的行径。他们的品格证明绝大多数是正面的，霍夫曼很好地隐藏了他的本性。
This indicated that he was capable of maintaining a double life and in complete control of his behaviour. Realising that his sanity would play a major role in his punishment, Hoffman changed tactics. He smashed the furniture in his cell and began writing bizarre letters. According to one addressed to the Homicide Squad, he claimed to have two times the amount of victims as Martin Rohack, a serial killer in the late 1500s. Rohack is believed to have the highest number of victims in the Czech lands, allegedly killing over 59 people in a four-year span.
这表明他有能力维持双重生活，并且完全控制自己的行为。意识到自己的精神状态将在判决中扮演重要角色，霍夫曼改变了策略。他砸碎了牢房里的家具，并开始写一些奇怪的信件。根据他写给凶杀案调查组的一封信，他声称自己受害者的数量是1500年代末连环杀手马丁·罗哈克（Martin Rohack）的两倍。人们认为罗哈克在捷克土地上的受害者人数最多，据称在四年内杀害了50多名（注：原文59人）人。
Hoffman also claimed to be innocent like Vera Brunner, a woman famous throughout Germany as a victim of miscarriage of justice. He also claimed he was the nephew of the British Queen, a member of a West German far-left militant organisation Red Army faction, and penned a letter to the Pope requesting admission into the strictest order of the Catholic Church. He painted his cell walls with threats, including one that read, I will cut off the head of the judge and throw it in a dog bowl. He demanded his murder weapon be returned so he could use it to bring the dead back
霍夫曼还声称自己像维拉·布伦纳（Vera Brunner）一样无辜，后者是一名作为司法不公受害者而在全德国闻名的女性。他还声称自己是英国女王的侄子、西德极左翼武装组织红军派的成员，并写信给教皇请求加入天主教最严格的修会。他在牢房墙壁上涂写威胁的话语，其中一条写着：“我要砍下法官的头，把它扔进狗碗里。”他要求归还他的凶器，以便他能用它让死者复活
to life. Hoffman first appeared in court in August 1974. The building was packed with onlookers as Hoffman, via sign language, tried to explain his motive. He detailed his extreme loneliness, alienation and isolation, and how that impacted his ability to have intimate relationships. These feelings then led him to commit the appalling acts. The defence argued that Hoffman was insane, but the prosecution thought differently.
。霍夫曼于1974年8月首次出庭。大楼里挤满了旁观者，霍夫曼通过手语试图解释他的动机。他详细讲述了他的极度孤独、疏离和孤立，以及这如何影响了他建立亲密关系的能力。这些感受随后导致他犯下了骇人听闻的罪行。辩护方辩称霍夫曼精神失常，但控方有不同看法。
It was the court's role to decide whether he should face trial for murder, or be judged unfit to plead, and face confinement in a mental health facility. Two psychiatrists who had studied Kurno Hoffman appeared in court. The first believed that the accused had lost touch with the world around him and was unfit to stand trial. His colleague disagreed, telling the court that Hoffman was responsible for his, quote, hysterical condition. The trial judge suspended court proceedings for two years as psychiatric experts debated
法院的职责是决定他是应该因谋杀罪受审，还是被判定不适合出庭受审，并面临在精神健康机构中被关押。两名曾研究过库诺·霍夫曼的精神病学家出庭作证。第一位认为被告已经与周围的世界失去了联系，不适合出庭受审。他的同事则持不同意见，告诉法庭霍夫曼应该为他“歇斯底里的状况”负责。审判法官中止了诉讼程序两年，同时精神病学专家们对
over Hoffman's sanity. During this time, Hoffman was moved between specialist clinics and psychiatric wards, where his psychosis was examined and treated. When he returned to court in July 1976, he appeared well, though his recollections of his crimes remained inconsistent. He claimed he acted in self-defense in both the Vestfriedhof mortuary and the Nuremberg Forest shootings. He alleged that Marcus Adler had surprised him while he was practicing shooting in the
霍夫曼的精神状态展开了辩论。在此期间，霍夫曼在专科诊所和精神病病房之间转来转去，他的精神病发作情况在那里得到了检查和治疗。当他于1976年7月重返法庭时，他看起来状态良好，尽管他对罪行的回忆仍然前后矛盾。他声称自己在西弗里德霍夫停尸房和纽伦堡森林枪击案中都是出于自卫。他辩称马库斯·阿德勒在他在树林里练枪时吓了他一跳，并把枪从他手里撞掉了。
woods and knocked the gun out of his hand. Following this assertion, questions were once again raised as to Hoffman's mental stability. Depending on the source, Kurno Hoffman's outcome varies. Some report that he never faced a full trial after being deemed criminally insane. This version ends with his indefinite detainment in a mental health facility. Adler, more reliable sources, state that he was ruled sane and faced court for at least the shooting attacks. They claim that Hoffman, described by the trial judge as a pitiful human being, was
这一说法出来后，人们对霍夫曼的精神稳定性再次提出了质疑。根据消息来源的不同，库诺·霍夫曼的结局也有所不同。一些人报告说，在被判定患有精神病不具备刑事责任能力后，他从未面临全面的审判。这个版本以他在精神健康机构中被无限期关押而告终。然而，更可靠的消息来源称，他被判定神志清醒，并因至少枪击袭击案而出庭受审。他们声称，霍夫曼被主审法官描述为一个可怜的人，他
sentenced to two life sentences for the murders of Marcus Adler and Ruth Lissie, with an additional 10 years for the attempted murder of Georg Varmut. While awaiting transfer to a federal penitentiary, he taunted jailers, requesting one final sip of a virgin's blood. There have also been reports that Hoffman was released in 2004 for reasons if true we couldn't ascertain. This ending has Hoffman returning to Nuremberg to live. These sources state that in 2008 the now 75-year-old was working on a memoir, though the status
因谋杀马库斯·阿德勒和露丝·利西而被判处两个无期徒刑，并因企图谋杀格奥尔格·瓦尔穆特而被判处额外10年监禁。在等待被转移到联邦监狱期间，他嘲弄狱警，要求最后抿一口处女的血。还有报道称，霍夫曼于2004年以如果属实我们也无法确定的原因获释。这个结局是霍夫曼回到纽伦堡生活。这些消息来源称，2008年，现年75岁的他正在写回忆录，尽管该书的进展状态尚不清楚。
of the work is unclear. Should you believe this to be the true ending to Kurno Hoffman's story, it is important to note that no one knows where he is today. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你相信这是库诺·霍夫曼故事的真实结局，那么重要的是要注意，没有人知道他今天在哪里。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。